Diana Egerton-Warburton
I describe the emergency department as like Narnia. It’s forever winter, and Christmas
doesn't come.
So we're always under intense pressure.
Previously we used to think of winter as our really hard time in the emergency
department, but now with heat health emergencies, it is all year round.
So summer is just as stressful.
We know that since European settlement, more people have died of heat
health emergencies than all the rest of the combined natural disasters together.
Heat is an insidious killer.
It's not a dramatic killer, and it's often the most vulnerable people in our society:
so the homeless, elderly people, young people, people with disabilities, they're
all more prone to be affected by heat health emergencies.